I think that the Republicans taking both
the house and the Senate will have
massive repercussions so I feel the same
way although I do feel like at 22 I
probably don't have enough life
experience to be the most credible
person aside from the fact that I'm
coming up through the context of
somebody who's totally disillusioned
with bipartisanship because it's all
I've really known and you're speaking to
a lot of people on that so yeah I mean
I'm shocked actually like since I've
been speaking out and being more vocal
about my own beliefs the amount of
people in my life that I would never
know think similarly or have similar
suspicions about the system new workers
who pretend that they're like yeah no
I'm totally blue I'm totally down the
line like no everyone's everyone
secretly has their doubts and has um a
lot more kind of forward party energy
than I think people realize
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to Ford
columnist for the New York Post co-host
of the podcast the Lost debate and
fellow political independent to size up
election day Ricky schlot welcome Ricky
thank you so much for having me I'm so
excited to be here excited to have you
so Ricky you have a fascinating origin
story where you and I were bonding over
our love for a book the cuddling of the
American Mind by my friend Jonathan
height and Greg lucianov yes and you
read this book and it had a profound
impact on you I did I read it my
freshman year of college and I am 22 so
I'm very much a member of gen Z and all
of their analysis was in part I looked
at myself and I said oh they're really
right and this is why I feel this way
and think this way and I looked around
me at the environment and thought I felt
a little like an ideological Outsider at
NYU at my time there and a lot of that
um kind of a liberalism that I was
seeing they diagnosed in such a concise
way without making it a partisan art
argument at all I think that they really
nailed it and just making making it
palatable to anybody who's actually
concerned about bettering my generation
and so it was a fabulous book I was
lucky enough to cross paths with Greg
lucianov for an on a an article that I
wrote a while ago I interviewed him for
the New York Post and that turned into a
fellowship at his organization and now
I'm actually co-authoring with him the
follow-up to the cuddling of the
American Minds The canceling of the
American mind and John will be writing
our intro so it's kind of amazing that a
book that made me kind of wake up from
my Slumber and become politically
interested and active and kind of
analyze what's around me is now
something that I'm able to do my small
part in contributing to the follow-up of
so well you're getting new fans all the
time because you are a genuine
independent you have your own
perspective and point of view and you
identify as a Libertarian is that right
yeah I do um I'm a registered
independent and I definitely would say
that I don't necessarily identify with
libertarian party but the ideology
definitely is where I kind of find
myself yeah yeah I see you as a
classical liberal along the lines of the
Frank fukuyama
school of thought yeah uh and well we're
looking at an historic election day I
mean people say every election day like
this most important one but yeah I feel
like this one is a big deal uh and you
and I are going to to let people know
what we think is going to happen on
Tuesday
I feel like
there was a point in the summer and I
wrote as much I said that uh it seemed
like the Democrats had this second or
third wind it was in the aftermath of
the Dobbs yeah decision uh and there was
a ton of energy and enthusiasm and now
it seems like the energy has flipped for
a number of reasons uh where I now
believe that the Republicans are going
to win the house uh by some number of
seats uh it's likely to be in my mind in
the low double digit range which would
be seismic uh and a lot of people are
trying to figure out whether the Senate
also flips so let's talk about the house
for a second first do you agree that it
seems like things are trending toward
the Republicans in these last days yeah
absolutely I think um it's undeniable
and I felt the same thing where I saw
following the Dobbs decision such a
renewed um kind of social political
energy versus the economic side that I
think we're seeing right now that has
um like we only have so much attention
to pay unfortunately to an issue like
that when you're going to the grocery
store and your bills through the roof or
you're filling up your your tank of gas
or you're really scraping by to make
rent and I think that the economic
realities and the sense that
um the current Administration has at
least in part exacerbated the inflation
situation is something that just keeps
hitting home for people even if
something like Dobbs is a is a big
abstract social reality I think it's a
little hard to run away from that and
then also the crime Optics as well I I
feel recently there's been a hard shift
towards conversation around things that
do help the Republicans in the end yeah
you live here in New York right yeah and
so crime is an issue a huge issue here
for sure
um I agree with you that inflation
um is still the dominant concern for
most Americans I saw one
correlation that gas prices going up and
the approval rating for the Democratic
administration were essentially
imperfect inverse lock steps yeah when
gas prices go up uh
then people are sad and that makes sense
I don't know if you drive a car nowadays
I don't I'm a pedestrian now so I I do
drive and I gotta say like I think uh
every time about the politics of it
anytime I stop stop and get gas but I
now feel like Republicans win the house
uh do would you project the same yeah I
think that
um at least in my sense from my vantage
point I think that's definitely the case
and I would say
um even anecdotally like this is total
anecdata but I I've been surprised by
some is that a new term I'm not sure
where I reflect that from but I don't
think it's an original Ricky ISM but um
I've I've been surprised by just how
much issues of crime have swayed my
female friends especially interesting
yeah particularly in New York I think
I've been surprised by the fact that
that's been
um something that people are acutely
aware of I don't know if that has
National implications but sir certainly
even from very Progressive friends of
mine I've heard that their political
decisions are going to be at least in
part informed by the fact that they feel
less safe here especially as young women
so so let's bring it to New York you
tweeted hey it looks like Lee zeldin
might actually be in this thing uh New
York turn red that race has tightened a
lot I have to say it would be
uh shocking if Kathy hokel were to lose
the gubernatorial race here in New York
to Lee zeldin Lee zeldin for those of
you who aren't in New York he's a trump
endorse he's I suppose a bit of an
election denier type so he's not even
what you'd consider sort of the
run-of-the-mill yeah like New York
moderate Republican yeah
um but he now is uh climbing quickly in
the polls with crime as a signature
issue yeah I mean they were um there was
a New York Post cover recently which I
mean I think he had just scraped Pastor
in one poll which might not be
representative of it by and large but I
think the fact that he's gotten as far
as he has even though to a lot of people
other aspects of his platform aren't
palatable goes to show how acute the
crime situation is being felt here yeah
I talked to a traditional Democrat who
said the same thing that some of your
girlfriends are saying um he said that
he's now a one-issue voter in his crime
and it's because was shot on his block
and he said when that happens then at
that point Nothing Else Matters uh and
and he's been disappointed by the
Democratic response to public safety
concerns because there seems like
there's uh something ideologically uh
holding them back where in his case and
he doesn't live in New York so I think
this is going to be a national issue
that um what his local officials were
saying
um was tying it to
bigger issues like poverty which may or
may not be wrong but it's not what you
want to hear when you're concerned about
someone being being shot absolutely on
your block so I think Kathy hokel still
pulls it out yeah I mean the Democratic
registration advantage in New York is I
think it's nearly two to one
um but I think it's going to be a nail
biter what do you think yeah I mean I I
would say I probably agree with you even
though I I think I take heart in the
fact that there's actually a competitive
race in the first place I'm not a huge
fan of either option but I think on the
on the crime front it's good to see that
there is a referendum on the status quo
here I mean there have just been like
egregious cases like Alvin Bragg's
office not going after the um but or
arresting the bodega guy who was clearly
in self-defense who ended up having his
wounds get infected in Rikers I don't
know if he followed that story but like
the Optics of um like an ideological
response to crime like you're talking
about I think having a strong referendum
on that is a healthy thing
um even if it means that that hokel does
still win I think that it's I think it
just puts a fire under some people's
butts right now to make a change and I
think it's very very necessary from
personal experience living here for sure
foreign
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
life doesn't come with a user manual you
know what I mean sometimes you have to
figure things out for yourself and
sometimes what you really need to figure
out is what's going on inside your mind
inside your brain therapists are people
who are trained to help us unpack our
thoughts our emotions how we are feeling
and make sense of it I first saw a
therapist when I was in my teenage years
and I've been a huge believer ever since
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed embedded therapists available
100 online and it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it cannot be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist learn more and
save 10 off your first month at Better
Health dot com slash Yang that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash get some help today
[Music]
I think that there's definitely going to
be a wake-up call uh I predict there's
going to be a republican upset somewhere
in the country where a race that you
would not expect yeah I was just seeing
today that in Washington state a state
that Biden won by uh you know 15 to 20
points or something like that they
actually are putting money in a lot of
these races you can tell what's going on
based upon the money Trail which brings
me to the U.S Senate races where most of
the attention is so anyone who keeps up
with me knows that I'm super into the
Evan McMullen versus Mike Lee race in
Utah are you uh uh excited about that
race or is that not something you've
been I've been following the fetterman
one a little bit more recently but one
general question that I do have for you
that I would really like to get an
answer to Is how do you feel about this
trend that I've seen more and more
candidates either refusing to debate or
just declining debates or at least
debating less than they normally would
have in the past well this is definitely
relevant for
okay okay this is a a great question so
this is a depressing but I think debates
are uh fading out more and more in part
because of the polarization and the
ideological nature and in large part
because there's typically someone who's
going to benefit from the debate the
underdog and someone who's potentially
going to lose the debate the favorite
I've now been in seven presidential
debates in four mayoral debates so I've
done a lot of these things and most
debates don't change anything that much
you tend to see it through your own
partisan lens and your your person
performs well in your own mind
um so debates are pivotal only when
they're outliers but I think we may have
just seen one of those outliers in the
John fetterman uh Dr Oz debate and my
feeling after that debate was they
should not have let him debate yeah
and do you feel that that means that
that makes someone unfit for office
uh I so what's interesting is that these
debates are in many ways an anachronism
to a time when you would have folks
actually stand next to each other and
evaluate them in various ways and then
it became this TV ritual
um I do think that there should be some
expectation and in John fetterman's case
it's a legitimate Health inquiry where
if you believe that a U.S senator might
have to
uh communicate and synthesize and yeah
um and uh do a lot of intellectual work
then if the person is not necessarily
going to be able to uh demonstrate those
capacities in a televised hour it's like
is that relevant yeah you know there are
a lot of people who are watching that
thinking like I don't care this guy is
on my team uh you know his policies are
going to align with mine um though the
reverse is true when you talk about
Herschel Walker where they would see
someone like Herschel Walker and you
know they're different
um people in different sets of issues it
makes me sad when candidates duck
debates
when another candidate typically the
underdog he jumps up and down and it's
like this person has to to bait me I'm
very sympathetic
um and it does worry me that I think
you're going to see more candidates duck
them it's one of the
symptoms of just how uh ossified and
dysfunctional our system is yeah where
people you think like look I've got
these voters or only two teams if I just
hang on to my voters I'm gonna win
um so why risk it I I do not like the uh
gubernatorial uh candidate in Arizona
ducking that debate like that yeah based
on the fact that her ideas are dangerous
and so they shouldn't be platformed
which to me feels like the perfect
opportunity to invite those ideas into a
debate and then slap them down if
they're so egregious yeah so for people
who don't know Arizona is more or less
Ground Zero for uh the
election denier takeover of the
Republican party in that state I'm
heading to Arizona in a couple weeks
um in part for this reason we've
endorsed Mark Kelly in the senate race
there but we have not endorsed in the
gubernatorial race and the Challenger is
a woman named Carrie Lake yeah who's a
TV personality seems very intelligenic
isn't it election denier
um and uh it seems like the Democratic
candidate
um whose Name Escapes Me TV hops I think
right Katie Hobbs I think that is I
think so um Katie Hobbs says look I'm
not going to to debate an election
denier
um is that
a justifiable rationale you know like in
my mind it's not a good look
um that race is going to go down to the
wire
um my feeling is that one reason why she
might not want to debate Carrie lake is
that Kerry lake is probably a very
talented performer yeah as a TV TV host
yeah yeah I mean I think I've looked at
the statistics that say that that to
your point debates don't tend to sway
people too much
um but I think this will be an
interesting round to kind of see how it
plays out because I would imagine that
my little prediction Theory here is that
the lack of debate might have a much
larger impact on the vote in the end
than a debate would have like I think
the Optics of saying like no I'm just
not going to do it or no I don't feel
like I owe it to voters might end up
harming people in the end I've looked at
the the statistics of like the typical
Senate race that used to be like 17
debates
um and like the top five races something
like that and it's like all the way down
to seven just over the past decade or
something roughly around there and I
think that's a troubling Trend if we see
our opponents as so far beyond the pale
that we can't even have a conversation
in the same language or even about
different issues of the election denying
problem is the the underlying take yeah
if that's the I mean that was the
rationale that Katie has expressed and
you're probably right that it's not
going to serve her candidacy well I do
think that incumbent members of Congress
get away with us all the time yeah
um because their upstart opponents might
not have the energy and traction to take
advantage of it and also one of the
things I'm seeing consistently is that
these debates will exclude uh quote
unquote minor party candidates or third
party where you have the Democrat the
Republican and then let's say a green or
a Libertarian sometimes
sometimes yeah yeah and uh big picture
the Republicans
um are saying they're going to boycott
the presidential debates in 24 I mean
it's a long time from now but that
they're they're saying look it's biased
against us you know we're not going to
to show up yeah
um so I hope debates go the other
direction where there are more of them
and they're more inclusive and you have
more people but the the trend is heading
the other way yeah it's really
disheartening because I think especially
for a lot of young people like the
statistics are incredible how much how
many of us are Independents and actually
are open to hearing different ideas and
don't necessarily just ascribe to one
belief like there's a statistic that
like the average gen zero is twice as
likely than the general electorate to be
a registered independent so yeah let's
go young people maybe you can still save
us and so I think it a forum like a
debate is actually really informative
for people who haven't just decided I'm
gonna check all the boxes all the way
down
um so I think it's really disappointing
I hope that um candidates that are just
totally walking away from it just
thinking that they have things taking
can take things for granted at least get
a little bit of a ding from it um in
terms of their voter turnout because I
think that's like the very least that
you owe a voter is I can stand up and
express my beliefs and and stand up to
the type of opposition that I will be
seeing in office even if I don't like
their views or I find them unpalatable
or I fundamentally disagree with them so
I found it to be disappointing but um I
think there's more and more independent
voters that want to be won over in a
debate I mean even my dad is 85 which I
was a very late addition to the family
and he after I guess since 1955 he
registered as a Republican and he just
told me the other day oh I re-registered
as an independent oh good job wow
so I think there's a whole swath of
people who want to hear different ideas
actually play out yeah anyone who
follows me and forward knows that I
think the answer is more democracy not
less and you're seeing it diminish
before our eyes in various ways
looking for a holiday gift for friends
and family forward is now on on
paperback my friends say the book is
[ __ ] awesome you can also buy swag at
boardparty.com it fits any size any
politics any human body yeah do it
[Music]
foreign
I thought that John Federman was going
to win that race until recently and now
I think Oz is going to squeak it out and
yeah I agree and so if
Dr Oz wins Pennsylvania
uh then
the odds of the Republicans winning the
Senate shoot up because that was the
Democrats best chance at adding a seat
uh my projection for the U.S Senate is
is that the Republicans narrowly win the
the senate in part because uh ozbeat
fetterman and I think lacks all uh beats
Cortez
masto in Nevada which makes me you know
it's I mean I don't know all of these
people I know some of them
um it's interesting this role because as
someone who's now trying to
revamp the system itself you know like I
don't want to be
um uh piling in on on one side of the
other and at this point we've endorsed
Republicans Independents and Democrats
um alike but
um I I think that the Republicans taking
both the house and the Senate will have
massive repercussions yeah I I feel the
same way oh that
although like at 22 I probably don't
have enough life experience to be the
most credible person aside from the fact
that I'm coming up through the context
of somebody who's totally disillusioned
with bipartisanship because it's all
I've really known and you're speaking to
a lot of people on that so yeah I mean
I'm shocked actually like since I've
been speaking out and being more vocal
about my own beliefs the amount of
people in my life that I would never
know think similarly or have similar
suspicions about the system that like
I'm the human repository for all the
like New Yorkers who pretend that
they're like yeah no I'm totally blue
I'm totally down the line like no
everyone's everyone secretly has their
doubts and has
um a lot more kind of forward party
energy than I think people realize yeah
I love it and you're activating a lot of
that energy too it takes someone who's
independent and principled and
intellectually courageous uh like
yourself because I know you know like
it's not easy to raise your hand and say
hey guys like I'm not sure this stuff is
yeah well it's shockingly it's been
pretty well received by and large but I
would say I in my limited realm of
expertise here that I feel the same way
that I think that there will be
um both the House and Senate going red
um yeah yeah I'm there too my big
prediction that might change things
somewhat is I think Evan McMullen pulls
it out in Utah and so I'm I was just in
Utah campaigning for Evan uh are you
into this race I haven't been
specifically no oh wait so I I have to
um to to get excited about it because
it's like the most important Senate race
in the country so check it out Evan
McMullen goes to the Middle East and is
a CIA operative for 11 years uh after 9
11. so 2001 to 2012. comes back
uh goes to Business School uh and then
is stunned by the rise of trump in 2016.
says this is uncool and so he runs as
essentially a republican protest
candidate in 2016 and gets 21 of the
vote in Utah okay where he's from he's a
Mormon
um uh and his now opponent Mike Lee
voted for Evan McMullen in 2016. because
at the time he wasn't that into Trump
yeah fast forward six years Evan
McMullen is running for Senate uh and
the Democrats of Utah decided not to run
a candidate okay
um because they knew that if they ran a
candidate they would lose to Mike Lee in
a state that Trump won by 21 points Mike
Lewis is going to Coast so they get out
of the way Evan McMullen uh now is
pulling neck and neck with Mike Lee and
if he wins he's saying that he will not
caucus with either party so he'd be a
genuine independent U.S senator who
might actually be the Difference Maker
between mean uh one one party or another
being able to pass everything or needing
his vote because he could be the Mansion
on the other side got it and
plus he's a great guy he's a principal
leader he actually
um
co-founded one of the organizations that
merged with the forward party this
summer so okay his people and forward
have like a ton of overlap
um so this could be a demonstration of
the fact that an independent can build a
coalition of Democrats Independents and
Republicans to defeat uh in this case
Mike Lee is also a trump endures Ted
Cruz indoors like that that type of
character
in a state that's reliably red what do
you think yeah I mean so actually my
funny little piece of context that I
have here is I don't know if you've seen
what Tucker Carlson has to say about him
oh yeah he called it he basically like
the classic like spoiler effect uh
argument or he is he's secretly a
Democrat and an independent Chief's
clothing which to me I was like totally
unconvinced by of like okay like
somebody somebody doesn't fit cleanly
and is therefore threatening to a
dwightfully candidate and so why I love
it
yeah um I think he was uh Tucker and
photoshopped his face on a McMuffin and
that was the the kind of best burn he
could come up with
um but I'd be really interested to see
if that if that happens I mean I think
that there needs to be more Mansion type
characters in in politics because not
necessarily his own personal viewpoints
but the idea that there could be someone
who's actually holding out of something
some enormous package doesn't actually
serve their their constituents should be
something that happens more and more in
our politics it's frightening to me to
see like Mansion become the darling of
the right and um Liz Cheney become the
darling of the left just because they're
somebody who's standing on a different
different area of just like one issue
and then all of a sudden they're they're
loved by the other party like why don't
we just have more nuanced interesting
different people well you know one of
the funny things that happened after I
left the Democratic party uh is that I
got requests to be on Fox every day for
weeks afterwards because uh anything
that kind of beats up one side they're
like oh come on
I was like that's not why I'm doing this
I'm trying to change the system and and
so I frankly declined uh you know versus
all of those
requests uh because we're trying to
build something
um new and exciting yeah that that
provides a home for folks who are
genuinely not spoken for uh on either
side one of the things that people don't
realize to the extent that they perhaps
should is that the 2024 Senate landscape
is very very dramatically tilted for
republicans and against Democrats
um so right now that this election uh is
Democrat the Democrats have a legitimate
chance to hold one thing we haven't
talked about is the Georgia race
um and I I what I think is going to
happen in Georgia is that uh and that
one's Reverend Warnock versus Herschel
Walker yeah
I think it goes to a runoff because
there's a Libertarian who's getting four
percent of the vote there and you need
50 to win outright so believe it or not
everyone and some of you remember this
from two years ago I think that the uh
politicos of the world are going to
descend on Georgia for another month
because the runoff would take place on
December 6th okay four weeks after so if
you can imagine but you know after all
of this energy
I'd be like hey guys it's Warnock a
one-on-one versus Walker yeah
um that would be fascinating to see yeah
um that their that race is I think
Warnock pulls it off when it's just the
the two of them um but I think the
entire thing is very close but I think
it goes to a runoff yeah I think I mean
Herschel Walker has just been like one
terrible headline after the next for his
race and I mean even just more broadly
the rise of the kind of celebrity
candidate to me is I just don't totally
love even Dr Oz is also like I just what
is going on I feel like just a decade
ago it would be unimaginable to have so
many of these like kind of pop cultury
figures I mean I to dream that Donald
Trump would have been our president
would have been I don't know so yeah
quite literally I think we're living in
one now but um so one of the things I
think sometimes Ricky is like what would
be the most uh effed up plot line and be
like that's probably what happens yeah
probably
um so and then also in Georgia one thing
that I found interesting that I haven't
really heard a succinct argument for is
that Stacey Abrams seems to be
struggling in the black community
specifically with black men which I
think surprised a lot of people in terms
of polling numbers
um I'd be interested to see how that
actually pans out yeah we should talk
about the gubernatorial races so it
looks like Stacy's going to fall short
to Camp
um and it also seems like she's running
behind Warnock like Warnock is and you
could also invert that and say Walker is
running behind Kemp which is accurate
campus is a relatively popular
established
Governor uh The Cece Abrams campaign
it's had a different energy than her
past campaign where it seemed like
everyone was in love with her and she
just fell short I mean the parallel
there is actually in my mind better of
work in Texas yeah um so full disclosure
I'm friends with Beto from the
presidential like I I like him
um but I I think that that they're both
uh running again in their their states
uh and I I think Stacy's going to
perform worse this time than she did
last time um I I wasn't aware of her
not getting that sort of support from
black men but when you say it out loud
it doesn't shock me yeah it's
interesting though just the I think it
was a surprise to most people watching
the polls there that that was where the
wind was kind of coming out of her sails
do you have a sense of why she might be
losing momentum over like her darling
status in the past you know I well I
think one of the the problems that
besets folks in a particular Lane
um is that as you are around for a
longer period of time you start uh
feeling like a bit more of like an
establishment figure yeah and so
um there there are folks then who just
feel a little bit less energized and I
don't think that's a healthy thing
necessarily because uh you know it's
like you can't always be that new
exciting yeah
um but I I and and there have been some
flubs or missteps in in that campaign
um that I think have been used against
her
foreign
in the past I've told you about how
important it is to protect your data and
your privacy online and how expressvpn
is a great tool I recommend to allow you
to do just that but that's not all that
expressvpn can do a fun feature is that
you can access a whole bunch of movies
and TV shows that are available only in
other countries which means there's a
whole lot more for you to watch than you
might be getting right now so for
instance I really really like the show
Vikings but it's not currently available
in the US on Netflix so to watch it all
I have to do is fire up expressvpn
change my location to Canada since
that's the country it's available in
refresh Netflix and then bang Vikings
you can choose from almost 100 different
countries and it's not just limited to
Netflix same goes for Hulu YouTube to
name a few and as always it works like a
charm there's no lag because it's
expressvpn so if you want to get access
to hundreds of new shows go to
expressvpn.com yang right now and you
can get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com com slash Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
so in terms of races around the country
are there any specific forward endorsed
people that you're keeping an eye on
well you'll be happy to know that if
someone wants to know about all the
forward endorsements you can go to
fordparty.com and also take a look at
last week's episode where like all we
did is talk forward I just talked about
Evan again because to me that's the most
exciting interesting uh Senate race but
we we have endorsed dozens of candidates
we're getting behind them I'm going to
be campaigning for some of them in the
days leading up to election day in
Nevada the other major one
um is this ballot initiative in Nevada
that would shift their voting process to
nonpartisan primaries and rank Choice
voting final five your must be a final
five fan I'm guessing yeah I am I
actually so I've literally just I was
telling you before I just submitted an
op-ed for the New York Post advocating
for open primaries and choice voting
normalize that with the older Republican
Community here but um I think even I I
don't I haven't really heard a lot of
good solid resistance to that uh
proposal I think it's mostly a lack of
people understanding the reason behind
it and so
um I wrote that op-ed specifically with
my own experience of just having moved
my voter registration to New York from
New Jersey where I was just living with
my parents before I moved here fully and
realizing that like oh I just lost my
total voice as an independent here in
terms of the the primary elections that
actually determine almost all of our
local politics and so I use that as a
lens because I just I see that there's a
huge lack of awareness around this issue
and if people actually listen to the
arguments of how this could moderate
things and probably we move us better to
a better mean of the political uh
opinions in a certain area I mean I
think bringing awareness to that as much
as possible is a great thing so well
it's on the bell in Nevada and I agree
with you with voters uh understand it
they're like interesting I can vote for
anyone I want eh yeah yeah yes you can
and I've heard a lot of Independents get
very upset about the fact that their tax
dollars are financing elections that
they may not be able to participate in
meaningfully because they're not
registered for one party or another yeah
I mean pretty much the Democratic
primary is what decides almost
everything that happens in New York City
and here I am just sitting on the
sidelines like well okay sure
um so I think bringing as much awareness
to that fact as possible is a good thing
I also think there's a lot of people on
the right who would be amenable to
things like that especially as there's a
fracture of the kind of Mega Republicans
and a huge swath of people who just
don't identify with that who might like
to see rather than the most extreme pull
polarized voters showing up at the
primaries to vote for America candidate
something that's actually closer to the
average of their view plants thank
goodness so ranked Choice voting was
used to choose Glenn youngkin for
the Virginia uh Governor yes and so
they're they're moderate Republicans are
like look guys this just helps us elect
people who are going to win yeah in the
general as opposed to someone who's more
of a Sarah palin-esque figure yeah ends
up failing in this process yeah totally
also the youngin race reminds me that
it's interesting how um how hot
education was as a topic for that that
cycle and it's just totally shifted I
think to I mean I think that's just kind
of on the back burner with inflation
with crime with
um with abortion and it's just totally
inverted those education stats break my
heart
um that where American kids reading and
math scores plummeted it's awful and I
think it's frustrating for a lot of
people who were kind of bringing the
alarm Bells pretty early on and saying
like these kids are the least at risk
Medical Group here and we also had data
very early on that showed that kids
don't transmit it to adults as readily
as adults do to each other and I think
it's for a lot of people who've been
suspicious of the school closure
policies it's super frustrating to see
this kind of like quiet gradual
admission that like yeah we absolutely
pulled the rug out from under the feet
of an entire generation of kids and
there's a real lack of accountability
and honesty uh the the if there's some
message I'd love for Ford to end up
representing is just a Reliance upon
facts uh and you know Democrats right
now continuously denigrate Republicans
as like election deniers or people who
deny certain facts but there have been
facts that Democrats have been uh very
happy to ignore or sweep under the rug
that didn't fit a particular uh
narrative and school closures is
probably in my mind top of that list
where look like we had data from other
countries other environments the risks
of having kids in school in terms of
getting sick were very very low but the
risks of them falling behind in their
education or their emotional development
were Sky High and I say this as a parent
you know I have a nine-year-old and a
seven-year-old and like we were living a
version of it and so we were like hey
guys you know I mean one of my ideas at
the time was like at a minimum during
the pleasant days of the fall in the
spring why don't we just let the kids
have school outside you know like they
can do an old school with a teacher that
image actually made me kind of happy but
there was zero effort in that direction
yeah it was really frustrating to watch
that happen and even
um as a very old kid during the pandemic
and a college student at the time I've
seen a lot of my friends are still
struggling with what happens when the
two years that you're supposed to be
networking with professor or going to
college fairs and figuring out what you
want to do and doing an actual
internship and realizing like oh I'm
glad that I'm not going into that field
now that was a good experience like all
the way up through developmental fees is
I think it's most acute the younger you
are but like for an entire generation of
people where they're going to have
lifelong impacts from from this and I
think it's I mean it's staggering even
to have seen the fact that there were
private schools open while Public
Schools across the street were closed
was just such an injustice I think it'll
exacerbate going down forward
um like into the future it'll exacerbate
in inequalities in a way that I don't
even think we can imagine right now in
terms of the learning loss and the
developmental loss there were Democrats
that raise their hands and say hey look
uh they're going to be disadvantaged
kids who get who suffer the most from
this and just completely ignored yeah I
mean it's it's really I think it's shy
talking I don't know that do you feel
that that's having still an effect on
this election cycle
I I think it is in the sense that there
right now is this uh pervasive uh
skepticism and mistrust of Institutions
yeah and I I think that's going to end
up feeding uh the Republicans frankly
though if you're watching this and you
still have a chance to a chance to vote
or listening don't take it as like hey
this is all baked like you can get out
and vote and maybe you can change
everything me and Ricky are saying
uh I was touching on this before so in
2024 there are many many vulnerable
Democratic senators in states that they
would be hard-pressed to win and you
mentioned one of them earlier Joe
manchin
Democratic senator in West Virginia
Trump won West Virginia by 28 points
it's a deep red State yeah and he's on
the ballot yeah uh as a Democrat John
tester in Montana I think uh Montana is
also deep red
um and so that there are several
Democratic senators that are going to
have a really really hard time uh
winning in 24. so this Senate race is in
many ways Democrats last chance to hold
the the senate for the foreseeable
um there are some noises oh my God I
don't know if I'm breaking any news here
but there are some noises about uh Joe
manchin running for president in 24
because he's unlikely to be able to win
his Senate race interesting and do you
think that that would be a successful
ticket or potentially a viable one uh
yeah I'm not sure who's going to be
excited for a Joe managing candidacy
because there are a lot of Democrats who
aren't fans I'm not sure if traditional
Republicans are going to be fans yeah um
there's I can't imagine that they would
be it but depends on who the opposite
ticket is though I mean if you had
another like Mega election type so I
think it's going to be Trump versus
Biden and then there's talk about
Mansion running on a Unity ticket you
think Biden's gonna pull it off for the
next go round when you say pull it off
what do you mean like I I mean I think
there's a good chance that he says I I'm
not ready for a whole another four years
I don't know I don't know if I feel like
he's got the mental acuity to go through
that many more years into the future
um so one thing that uh we're seeing is
that the midterms will affect Joe's uh
stance and attitude toward running again
yeah but right now he's planning on
running again and he's planning on
running again in part because it seems
like Trump's coming up the other side
and Joe feels like it's got his
god-given responsibility to defeat Trump
he's done it once he's not sure who else
can do it uh and so he's going there I'm
not sure that he can do it I don't know
like I just at the Optics of another
Biden and Trump election just really is
disheartening to me like I would the
idea of like a third election where I
think that almost everyone is saying I
don't totally love who I'm voting for
but I'm voting for them oh I don't know
so you think DeSantis there's no way
that he's he's uh taking over Trump's
spot here I think if Trump runs he wins
I think Trump has 50 so the Republican
field uh looks like here are some of the
folks that I I think are running
Chris Christie runs Larry Hogan runs
Mike Pompeo runs Mike Pence runs
um Trump runs um and then uh there'll be
a couple of others uh and then I I think
Trump gets his 40 to 50 percent and then
everyone else splits the other 50 and he
ends up rolling the big question mark is
DeSantis but if you're DeSantis you sit
it out you're The Heir Apparent neck
cycle and if you go in then it's like a
death match between
um him and and Trump did make DeSantis I
mean that is like accurate so I I think
Trump winds up the Republican nominee
and then Joe feels like he has to run
and I I said on CNN the other day that
if Joe runs then the Democrats will
clear the field and not let anyone run
against him and then there's someone
from outside of the democratic
establishment says I'm going to run
against him and I suggested Nina Turner
has a possibility because Nina's like
whatever she doesn't care with the
Democrats
yeah that the DNC would quietly just uh
like
Short Circuit the process because the
last thing they'd want is 81 year old
Joe Biden debating Nina Turner five
times yeah or Marianne Williamson and
then
um Paul bagala was like that I was like
how are they going to do that they can't
do that and I was like well I guess
we'll find out together but like I can't
imagine that Democrats would have a
robust process if Joe was going to run
and Trump's coming up the other side
yeah um so this is the way I see it
shaking out right now but it could
change if Joe doesn't run then you're
gonna see uh a dog pile of democratic
candidates piling yeah and which it
sounds like that's what you think is
going to happen that's what I mean I
would just hope for a new pile on both
sides but it might be a little
idealistic but I don't know I just I I
can't imagine especially looking at the
approval ratings of younger people with
Biden which
um like he tanked like 20 with Gen Z in
terms of how excited we are about him
going into the presidency and where we
are now and I think
I don't know I think there's like such a
lack of Youth excitement about about Joe
I don't know I I don't know if he can
muster people especially a whole new
generation of Voters to be super excited
about him I think it's like a like a
well it's better than the other option
kind of person but to your point 58 of
Americans would not be excited about
either Trump or Biden which leaves an
opening a mile wide yeah um for a Unity
ticket or something along those lines
which is some of what's fueling the the
thought of a Joe manchin yeah plus let's
say Liz Cheney run yeah like that that's
that'd be interesting yeah yeah so yeah
so my argument is that look
um uh you need an organic process that
ends up including people and feels
genuinely Grassroots and Democratic yeah
um and then you could get energy around
different types of people just like a
different flavor of
establishment is not necessarily what a
lot of folks are looking for absolutely
but you should know that some of these
things are are probably coming down the
pike from what I'm hearing yeah yeah I
mean I've heard I've heard the same but
I am surprised of something
sure he's had so many
bad like news cycles and headlines and
blunders that I don't know what's going
to come down between now and 24 but
um I don't know but if if that means
clearing the clearing the space for an
actual formidable
um non-partisan candidate I'm I'll be
excited about that I'll look forward to
seeing it well you know I do have those
conversations so there you have it about
election day 2022 get out and vote make
your voice heard if you still have the
chance to support candidates Under the
Sun I'm obviously an Evan McMullen fan
I'm a final five voting in Nevada fan
but just find people that that are worth
supporting uh and we'll see if we can't
maybe surprise some people in in some
way you might even surprise me and Ricky
because you've heard what we think is
going to happen and you know maybe we'll
we'll end up putting our feet in our
mouths right now or in a way because
it's funny one of the things I'm saying
is like look there are things I want to
happen and things I think will happen
yeah
um so some of the things I've I've
described today like this is what I I
think will happen but I you know I'd be
happy to be wrong yeah I I'd be happy to
be surprised in some places I think
that's what a healthy democracy does is
you know actually once in a while
there's the surprise candidate that no
one would ever really expect to pull
through because that's the will of the
voter and I think there have been too
many that have been in the bag so I'd be
happy to be wrong on on predictions well
so I I I I think we are going to be
surprised somewhere in the landscape
where uh an underdog is going to pull
out an upset and I think that Underdog
is likely to be
um like a Lee zeld and type Republican
where yeah they're like oh you're not
going to win in a blue State and then a
lot of Voters is quietly filed in yeah
and I don't know I wouldn't be totally
Florida if seldom pulls it off but yeah
no it's I mean at this point you know
like that like I I expect that there's
going to be some uh some result that
people will like will look at and say
like wow that's nearly unprecedented
well let's we'll recoup and see who it
was we'll see how we did but again make
your voice heard get out and support
candidates if you want to see the
candidates that we're backing It Forward
go to fordparty.com endorsements Ricky
thank you so much where can people catch
up with you thank you
um so I guess the best place would be at
Twitter just Ricky schlotz may handle
and kind of aggregate all my different
stuff there and
um yeah and when the book comes out in
September um it'll all be on my Twitter
page so well Ricky thank you for being a
role model and voice for the Next
Generation uh appreciate that the heck
out of you thank you I really appreciate
that and thanks for inspiring me to do
that
uh yeah I mean I I'm I'm just benefiting
from it like everyone else
[Music]